اكثر من مناوره عسكريه وتاي وتفهمها جيدا
تدرك تايبي حجم التهديد ان وقع المحظور
تزداد وتيره المناوره الصينيه العسكريه
رسائل تريد لها بكين ان تكون قويه وشديده
اما تيبيه فترد تدريبا وتسليحا اخر
الاستعدادات للاسواق تمديد الخدمه
العسكريه الالزاميه من اربعه اشهر الى عام
واحد بدايه العام 2024 غير ان الجيش
التايواني يواجه صعوبه في التجنيد بدوام
كامل وبالاحتفاظ بالعسكر لقله الحوافذ
الماليه طيبه لا تملك الا ان ترد بتكثيف
تدريب جنودها وتعزيز الدفاعاتها بزياده
المشتريات من الطائرات المقاتله والصواريخ
المضادات للسفن
لكن هذا ليس كافيا بحسب خبراء ففي حال
وقوع النزاع فان تعداد الجيش الصيني الذي
يبلغ مليون جندي وتفوقه العسكري يتجاوز
الى حد كبير عديد الجيش التايواني الذي
يبلغ
88,000
الا ان تلك المقاييس قد لا تعني سيطره
عسكريه صينيه في ما لو قررت غزوه يون
فسيناريو روسيا في اوكرانيا ما زال حاضرا
الواضح ان بكين لا تتردد في ارسال رسائلها
المباشره ترد على استفزازات وعلى تواطئ
بين واشنطن لا بل وتصاعد فالتدريبات
الصينيه الاخيره هي الاكبر منذ ان زارت
رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي نانسي طيبه
اغسطس الماضي